>> I'M RAYMOND ARROYO SITTING IN
FOR LAURA INGRAHAM.
WE SHOWED VIDEOS OF HOOLIGANS
THROWING WATER AT NEW YORK CITY
POLICE OFFICERS IN BROOKLYN.
AND THEN ANOTHER ATTACK.
SHOWING AN OFFICER MAKING AN
ARREST IN HARLEM GETTING
DRENCHED WITH WATER AND THEN HIT
IN THE HEAD WITH A BUCKET.
IN THE DAYS AND WEEKS TO FOLLOW,
MORE VIDEOS OF PEOPLE
DISRESPECTING POLICE HAVE
SURFACED.
THESE ATTACKS ARE ESCALATING.
THE "NEW YORK POST" REPORTS.
CHUNK OF CONCRETE, BOTTLES
THROWN AT NYPD COPS IN SEPARATE
INCIDENTS.
ATTACKS LIKE THESE HAVE MOVED
FROM NEW YORK STATE GOP TO
LAWMAKERS TO PROPOSED
LEGISLATION MAKING IT A FELONY
TO DUMPING WATER ON COPS.
SOME DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO
STOP IT.
JOINING ME IS BERNIE KERIK.
>> WHAT THIS DOES, IT EMBOLDENS
THESE GUYS THAT GO OUT AND DO
THIS STUFF.
THEY SEE IT ON VIDEO.
THERE'S COPYCAT ATTACKS.
WE'RE SEEING IT NOT ONLY IN NEW
YORK CITY.
IN NEW YORK CITY WE'VE SEEN A
NUMBER OF THEM.
THE NEW YORK CITY COPS HAVE LAID
BACK.
THEY'RE AFRAID OF THE MAYOR.
THEY'RE CONCERNED THEY'LL NEVER
BEEN SUPPORTED BY THE MAYOR.
THE MAYOR SAID WE'RE GOING TO
ARREST THEM.
THEY'RE ARRESTING THEM AFTER THE
FACT BECAUSE OF PUBLIC PRESSURE.
THE COPS SHOULD NOT BE AFRAID TO
DO THEIR JOB BECAUSE WE HAVE A
WEAK MAYOR.
>> Raymond: AND DO IT IN THE
MOMENT.
>> YEAH.
THERE'S PLENTY OF CHARGES,
WHETHER IT'S CRIMINAL MISCHIEF,
DISORDERLY CONDUCT, HARASSMENT,
ASSAULT.
PLENTY OF CHARGES THESE PEOPLE
COULD HAVE BEEN CHARGED WITH BUT
WERE NOT.
I SEE COPS THAT ARE AFRAID TO DO
THEIR JOB BECAUSE OF THE MAYOR
THAT IS AN ANTI COP MAYOR.
>> Raymond: SEAN HANNITY ASKED
de BLASIO ABOUT THIS.
WE'LL PLAY THE CLIP.
WATCH.
>> HERE'S MY QUESTION FOR YOU.
EVERY PERSON ON VIDEO THAT HAS
COMMITTED A CRIME -- EVERY --
>> LOOK AT THAT GUY.
>> YOU SEE WHAT HE JUST DID?
>> THIS IS INCREDIBLE.
>> THAT'S NOT A GOOD ENOUGH
STATEMENT.
EVERYBODY THAT COMMIT AS CRIME
WILL BE BROUGHT TO JUSTICE.
>> OUR POLICE OFFICERS KNOW WHO
COMMITS A CRIME AND THEY WILL
BRING THEM --
>> Raymond: WHAT KIND OF
MESSAGE --
>> YOU'RE LOOKING AT A GUY THAT
HAS VILLAINIZED COPS DATING BACK
TO WHEN HIS SON WAS YOUNG AND HE
TOLD HIS SON THAT YOU NEED TO
WATCH OUT FOR THE MEN AND WOMEN
IN THE NEW YORK CITY POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
DON'T GIVE ME THIS GARBAGE NOW
EVERYBODY WILL BE ARRESTED.
THAT'S NOT THE MENTALITY OF THIS
MAYOR.
THIS MAYOR VILLAINIZES THE COPS.
HE'S DONE IT CONSISTENTLY.
THE MEN AND THE WOMEN IN NEW
YORK CITY KNOW IT.
>> THIS IS GOVERNOR ANDREW
CUOMO.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID ABOUT THE
STATE OF THE COP ATTACKS.
>> THE VIDEO OF THE COPS GETTING
DOUSED WITH WATER AND WALKING
AWAY IS 1 OF THE MOST
DISTURBING, EMBARRASSING
SITUATIONS.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS.
IF THAT EVER HAPPENED TO THE
STATE POLICE, WOULD BET YOU MY
BOTTOM DOLLAR THAT YOU WOULDN'T
SEE STATE POLICE OFFICERS
ASSAULTED AND THEY TURN AROUND
AND THEY GET BACK INTO THE CAR.
>> Raymond: YOUR RESPONSE.
>> LISTEN.
I'D AGREE WITH HIM THAT IT'S
DISGUSTING AND DISTURBING.
BUT IT'S THE DEMOCRATS THAT ARE
EMBOLDENING PEOPLE TO DO THIS
TYPE OF BEHAVIOR.
IF WE HAD GOVERNORS AND MAYORS
AND LEGISLATORS THAT WERE
SUPPORTING THE MEN AND WOMEN IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THERE WOULD BE
A DIFFERENT MINDSET.
THE COPS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
DATING FROM FERGUSON TILL NOW,
THEY'RE AFRAID TO DO THEIR JOB.
THEY'RE HANDCUFFED.
>> Raymond: WE'RE HEARING
REPORTS FROM TIMES SQUARE ON
THIS FOURTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
MICHAEL BROWN AFFAIR THAT THERE
WAS ANOTHER COP THAT WAS JUMPED
DURING AN ARREST IN TIMES
SQUARE.
HOW LONG WILL THIS GO ON AND
WHEN DOES SOMEBODY EITHER IN THE
POLITICAL STATE OR NATIONAL
LEVEL STEP IN AND EMPOWER THESE
OFFICERS TO DO THEIR JOB AND
PROTECT THEMSELVES?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS?
THIS GOES BACK TO RUDY GULIANI.
THINGS HAVE TO GET COMPLETELY
OUT OF HAND.
THE CRIME RATE WILL GO UP.
PEOPLE IN THE CITY WILL BE
AFRAID AND THEN AND ONLY THEN
WILL THEY ELECT SOMEBODY THAT
GETS OUT IN THE STREET AND LETS
THE COPS DO THEIR JOB.
THIS IS ONLY GOING TO GET WORSE.
>> Raymond: DO WE HAVE THE
VIDEO?
WE HAVE.
MICHAEL BROWN PROTEST.
THIS IS JUST IN, BY THE WAY.
IN A MOMENT YOU'LL SEE THE COPS
ATTEMPTING TO ARREST SOMEBODY.
THEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE ATTACKING
THESE OFFICERS WHILE THEY'RE
TRYING TO PROTECT CITIZENS IN
WHAT SHOULD BE A STREET AND IS
NOW A PEDESTRIAN PLAZA.
WATCH THIS.
THE COPS ARE SURROUNDED BY THESE
PROTESTERS.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS.
>> ALL I CAN SAY IS, UNDER RUDY
GULIANI THAT STUFF WOULDN'T
HAPPEN.
HE WOULD NOT ALLOW IT.
FOR THIS TO GO ON, THESE COPS
ARE BASICALLY -- THEY'RE A
CODDLE --
>> Raymond: THEY'RE AFRAID.
THE CAMERAS MAKE THEM MORE